In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from 820th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr Thelelius.
On the 20th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Thelelius and his companions
Alexander and Asterius.
Saint Thelelius came from a Christian family of Phoenicia in Lebanon.
It is said that his father was a bishop of the region.
Instructed in the fear of God and full of tender compassion for suffering humanity, he had
also been instructed in the art of medicine, and from his youth practiced it without charge
for the sick of all conditions.
He would go himself and seek out the disabled and would carry them on his shoulders back to
the family house that he had transformed into a refuge, where he lovingly took care
of them.
He made no distinction between Christians and pagans, and as payment for his services, he only
asked that the pagans believe in Jesus Christ, the only physician of body and soul.
During the reign of Nmerian, around 283 and 284, when he was only 18 years old, having received
from the Lord the same grace as the apostles, Thelelius journeyed through towns and villages
preaching the good news of the kingdom, healing the sick, cleansing lepers, and casting out
demons by the sign of the life-giving cross.
Arriving in the coastal town of Agia, he converted a great number of pagans.
After being denounced, he was arrested by soldiers, while he was hiding in the trunk of an olive
tree, and taken back to Agia, where he was brought before the tribunal of the governor,
Theodore.
The saint replied boldly to the governor's questions, who then ordered that his ankles be pierced,
so that a rope could be passed through the holes, and the saint strung upside down.
But suddenly blinded by divine power, the soldiers pierced and suspended a piece of wood instead
of the saint, furious and thinking that they were mocking him, Theodore had them beaten,
and gave the order to beat Thelelius.
The holy martyr remained immovable under the torture, as though he felt no pain, for his
love of God raised him above bodily suffering.
The magistrate then decided to change his tactics, and asked Thelelius whether he cured the sick
through magical arts, or by the power of the gods.
Taking those whom he had cured as testimony, he proclaimed that only the name of Christ and
the power of the cross were able to heal every ill, for the son of God, in his compassion
for our nature, had come among us as a human being, in order to deliver our nature from death
and corruption, and had transmitted this grace to his apostles and their successors before
ascending to heaven.
Seeing that the people were listening with pleasure to the saint's words, Theodore rushed
towards him with fury, but his arms were suddenly paralyzed.
Far from being softened by this punishment, he delivered Thelelius up to horrible tortures.
Comforted by Christ invisibly present with him, the saint endured the iron nails and flames
with joy, crying out that he preferred to remain faithful and die, rather than buy a perishable
existence at the price of apostasy, and then he considered it his duty to sacrifice his
life for the one who had given his own for our salvation.
They then abandoned him in a skiff on the open sea, but as soon as Thelelius prayed, the sea
became calm, and he was gently carried to the shore.
Immediately seized again by the soldiers he was taken back to Agia and dragged once more
before the tribunal, where a great crowd had gathered.
The town's physicians, jealous of his success, urged the governor to finish with him as quickly
as possible, and so great was their success that the latter ordered that he be nailed to
a plank and boiled tar be poured over his body, after which he be delivered to the flames.
At first filled with emotion and perspiring like an athlete who measures his strength before
the contest, Thelelius was immediately strengthened by the grace of God and proclaimed that he
saw the tortures as a joy and as a cause for boasting.
He was then thrown to the lions but the beasts as they drew near began to frolic around him
wagging their tails.
As the tortures were only serving to add to the saints trophies, Theodore finally had
him beheaded.
This glorious end led others who were present to the faith.
Besides the soldier Alexander and the wood carrier Asterius who had been converted during
the saint's first interrogation and who were immediately beheaded, many others were converted
and valiantly witness to their faith, including Thelelius's teacher in the medical arts and
the citizens, Storonus, Filegrius, Timothy, Theldulia and Macrina.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.